just a heads up this episode
it's a little weird weird app not our
best kooky guest we didn't know what the
hell was going on but
good luck with it we tried we tried
[Music]
hey folks we might be drunk we're here
this is it oh shoot maybe I jumped the
gun here I think they like all the fun
uh yeah there you go okay because I want
to talk into the mic that would help let
me explain my years in Show Business
look at Al Franken everybody how
freaking heavy big ass first our first
Senator ever hey
if you need to know orange Hat's not
funny not a lot of senators or
politicians with comedy backgrounds
he actually what was funny about him he
writes songs or did he's gone Lauren
yeah uh but he was wrote songs and I
when I first got to the Senate just to
I'd visit other Senators to get to know
them and he played me a couple of the
songs he wrote and they weren't bad and
actually and he didn't write the music
he wrote the lyrics pull it up so I
told him I said I have a song and I need
I need something and it was a country
western duet we stayed together for the
kids it was what we thought we had to do
uh wow sounds like you were cold is a
flashback anyway so so because he had
written this country thing and then we
ended up writing a verse together it
wasn't very good yeah but still it was
bonding right right he was on the
Judiciary Committee which I was on and
help them that much and what's scarier
doing new jokes or being on that senate
floor that seems terrifying so serious
it's the opposite of Comedy
I'll tell you something on
there was never a moment on the senate
floor or I was afraid that a joke
wouldn't work
as well
there's usually no one listening usually
most people go to do a Florida speech
they're either alone or are they anyone
there so no it's uh
working on a new piece yeah
well doing in front of an audience yeah
that's a little scary okay that room
it's like politicians will get a laugh
the way like a musician in between songs
get the huge pop right you listen to
certain like those old Sinatra albums
you're like this guy's [ __ ] killing I
know it's nothing it's nothing yeah well
you mean funny like laughs he's getting
laughs oh yeah because the bar is low
he'll be like he'll be in Vegas like uh
you guys lost a bunch of money huh
they're like ah we did well that is
funny
they don't say something racist why
because they gamble there
you didn't understand it sorry that's
the problem
this is your first episode with a
wedding ring by the way oh yeah no
married oh congratulations yeah he's a
lucky guy
uh but yeah just this weekend so
that is long you stayed together for the
kids that's right get this guy up here
right now
to drink a call back look at the uh you
can see the horse manure in the photo
which I love on the right yeah good
times oh my God so this is where this is
in uh Lujan oh no okay
come on it's New Orleans yeah okay but
yeah good times we had to do the
traditional second line which you know
is appropriation but the white people
love it it is appropriation yeah that's
we the night I got there was Wednesday
night I'm with a buddy Stavros who you
know listeners no bigger guy hilarious
comic Ari shaffir we're out we end up we
get so drunk we end up at a gas station
eating fried oysters fried soft shell
crab Fried Chicken wasted we're in the
lobby of the hotel just scarfing it down
yeah and I just turned a stove and I'm
like man imagine eating this [ __ ] sober
and stuff goes I haven't had one drink
it looks like a mob he doesn't need to
get drunk for gas stations
well so I feel cramp I mean
at a gas station it's it's dicey that's
a gamble it was a game in New Orleans
yeah yeah
yes that does help opposite chances but
first of all if you're getting a soft
shell crab at a gas station it's in New
Orleans that's a good point it's not
Rockaway County that is good right right
by the way what are you drinking by the
way what soda you get a soft shell crab
at a gas station here yeah that's a
that's your day move in Minnesota okay
what do we got here
Coney Island there you could get a soft
shell maybe I had my first fried soft
shell crab at Coney Island I did come on
I am not kidding you I was like
11 years old yeah my uh I I live in
Minnesota my uncle and my cousin lived
in uh Cedarhurst Long Island very the
five towns very Jewish sure and they
took me to Coney Island to a Nathan's oh
yeah and they had I had a fried soft
shell crab on a bun
and I went Jesus Christ this is good oh
it's so good that's why I wasn't I
didn't even hear a gas station
crab in New Orleans yeah are you from
New York I was born in New York lived in
New Jersey until I was four and then
moved to a little town in southern
Minnesota thank you oh okay so you are
you know about Minnesota I know about
Minnesota yeah the winners
back to New York you must have played
Minnesota many times I love you isn't
that great I've got an Acme Comedy Club
I just did like uh six shows in a row
there just I was trying to get like
you're working out do a lot of [ __ ] yeah
well I like doing a lot of shows you
guys know like of course how do you get
any good unless you do them all in a row
right here here is this uh tell that to
the tick tockers
cheers
there you go wow when's the last time
you drank with a senator uh Mitch
McConnell a couple weeks ago
that is sour
really good
that's what you guys got it too yeah I
like it I like a bitter but this has
lime in it lime lager okay a limerick uh
yeah so Minnesota do you do you have a
lot of love for that state yeah of
course yeah yeah that's where I grew up
but yeah I love Minnesota and when
you're Senator you go all around the
state and you and you meet
that's
you meet everybody and of all political
Persuasions you also like meet people in
disasters like if there's a flood or a
tornado and you see people at their very
often at their best right because uh and
you see people step up for their
neighbors they're really moving actually
it's like 9 11. people came together I
remember that was I was here that that
day and I remember you line up everyone
line up to donate blood and everyone's
like yeah we're good I'm blood
everyone did it yeah it was just New
Yorkers you know that is nice well that
was yeah more tragedy than we've ever
actually had and yeah that was
I was in Minnesota that day and uh it
was my family was here in New York
during SNL it was all those years I was
in New York it wasn't an SNL then but
um my family was because all right
that's where I raised my kids and so
uh yeah I ended up driving back I was I
was visiting my mom
and um then drove back
um
because the planes planes weren't flying
so it should be back all night and one
day and I got oh God damn that was a
shitty [ __ ]
that was so [ __ ] awful so then you
moved back to New York uh 1975 for a
little program called Saturday Night
Live
was that the year you started writing on
it
yes I was one of the original SNL
writers are you original oh yeah oh gee
me and Tom Davis uh Tom and I went to
high school together in Minneapolis for
a suburb Minneapolis and uh yeah we were
to the
original writers Lauren uh we were the
only writers Lauren higher whom he
hadn't met
but we submitted Cemetery what did you
uh do they see at a comedy show I assume
no uh a an agent a William Morris agent
saw us at The Comedy Store and
um he's in L.A this is in L.A and we had
uh moved there after I graduated college
we moved out there we're just two years
and uh this William Moore's agent said
your Taylor Swift material is really
good would you like to write for a
comedy rice on TV we said yeah but there
are none that we could write for there
was a Tonight Show yep which was really
good but we couldn't it was Marty Mighty
Carson hard players and uh the monologue
and we weren't that wasn't us there's
Carol Burnett which was a great show I
love Carol button we were not right for
and then there was sunny and Cher which
was
kind of shitty yeah yeah and so he said
we said he said write for write a
package for a show that you'd like to
see and so we wrote a news show parody
we wrote A Sketch which was a parody of
Sonny and chair we wrote a commercial
parody and we wrote a conceptual film it
was 14 pages long so this is for Jesus
anyone uh listening watching
it when you submit comedy material don't
write too much you guys must have had to
have some packets a nephew of some
friend uh or submit stuff to you that's
six pages long and you know after
a page yeah yeah right of course so
don't do that do something short and
make sure keep them one and more but you
kind of laid out the blueprint for the
whole show the the commercial parody the
news the sketch did they ask for that or
was that just what you decided no that's
what we did and then the the World War
III thing was not like a new update it
was just it was it was a newscast the
night of the day of World War III so it
was like tragedy death catastrophe I
like tonight's news after this message
do commercial parodies because now every
commercial I see I'm like that's
sexually strong they're in like too many
real commercials commercial parodies now
I never thought about that they do both
they do both yeah and the but the ones
that are real whoa
look at those shoulders yeah I think
that's uh great jawline
uh but first we'd like to introduce some
very important people in the audience
you know oh I know this one is stand
behind every successful man you'll find
a woman and Tom and I are certainly no
exception so tonight ladies and
gentlemen I'd like you all to meet my
lovely wife Darlene she's sitting up
there Navy baby can we get a shot up
there she is she's over there there
ladies and gentlemen my lovely wife
Darlene hey
store sitting next story is our son Al
Jr
is nine years old and he's already in
the second grade
um
Junior ladies and gentlemen Suzanne the
girl Tom lives with
no I I can't I can't let this fly any
longer ladies and gentlemen I'll just
introduce his family and the girl I
supposedly live with representative
Passat no now with all the Anita Brian's
stuff going on with all the defeat of
gay rights all across the United States
some people have to stand up and be
accounted I think no no the truth no I
mean the truth of the matter is Al and I
are homosexual lovers
why are you shirtless because we're out
to do the reason we're shirtless is the
premise is we've gone out to do a sumo
wrestler piece
always would come out in some costume
yeah and it would never be what we were
doing right the skinniest man on the
planet is the Sumo so then it's um yeah
this is where gay lovers or in the
parlance of then homosexual lovers and
that and then uh the boy stands up and
goes I hate you Daddy I hate you I hate
you I hate you I hate you it was oh
that's great this is 1976. or something
like that and
yeah that would play today
I think so but the dad would hate you
for hiding it he'd be like you should be
proud of being gay the uh first bit we
ever did on the show was the Bureau of
what uh was uh called powwow with the
press and it was what if the Indians had
won and I was a host of powwow with the
press and Tom was the guy from the
Bureau of white man Affairs
and that was basically the premise was
what if the Indians had won and you know
we talked about the nicknames for the
major league cross teams oh that's
killer screaming Rabbi on the Cleveland
[ __ ]
that kind of thing I love it yeah it was
uh and that was you know
that was 1977 so that is uh how many
years you know almost what 45 years or
44 years before they changed the name of
the Redskins right she called it yeah we
were we called and uh commanders and
commanders and the Indians commanders is
a horrible name it's both are not great
they're not Guardians at least has like
some significance to Cleveland yeah does
it yeah because they're the Guardians
yeah look it up it's like some sort of
Protectors of Cleveland it has some sort
of historical I forgot what it was but
then commanders excuse me who's murals
awesome oh yeah also there's usually one
Commander
right oh yeah good point because usually
you have one person in command it's like
the CEO this is from my government
experience
well yeah you're looking at more than
one Commander it's like a leader you're
on this original SNL cast which is so
many Legends I wasn't on the camera no
no but you're part of the cat you're a
writer you came you were you were in the
cast what year did you join the cast
lady I never Tom and I were never in the
cast I was never in the cast we were
always a featured player that's the ones
and they don't say end featuring and
remember they do the cast and everything
so I was never I was probably a featured
player in more seasons than anybody but
right I did 15 Seasons 15 seasons one of
the advantage of me because I was one of
the people originally is and so who
pointed this at me was Norm Macdonald
that I never had to
go to the show having not been there I
mean in other words it's really
nerve-wracking for people to come to
Saturday Night Live and start enjoying
it right
and I never had to do that basically you
were there day one did you still feel
the pressure though
uh Woody Allen once said comedy is
either easy or it's impossible
and if it's easy there was nothing more
fun right Tuesday night you know
Wednesday morning rolling on the floor
laughing and stuff and uh it was
horrible if you couldn't think of
anything
yeah yeah did you know Woody at all
I've met him a couple times just very
very briefly so I don't know no how
about I have a question was Chevy Chase
as big a dick as everyone says
it depends uh how big a dick they say
Chevy I think will be the first to admit
that he can be at times a little
critical of people and mean or something
like that so yeah he he had that but you
know he was funny boy and yeah he was
first hired as a writer he was not a
cast member didn't he only do how long
was he on the cast a year and a half
star because of update and I remember
when he left he got married he was gonna
going out to Hollywood and make movies
and he did uh but you know there were
some people going like no no don't let
him go he's the show and then of course
we had bullution Aykroyd and yeah and
Jane Lorraine and Gilda and then Billy
Bill Murray king that's crazy
I was I was there I guess I didn't see
it I didn't see it at all would you feel
the tension though not really but you
know maybe I was oblivious yeah I don't
know there's a lot of stuff bubbling up
about Bill Murray now being
inappropriate or a dick did you see that
or is that just par for the course Billy
um could could be a bully a little bit
of a bully boy uh but he's a sweetheart
when you're with him but I think when he
works he gets
it can be difficult all right it is
weird on Twitter now they're just trying
to cancel people for being dicks I know
where you're just kind of like all right
like it started with like salad first
off you got I think completely [ __ ] oh
I really think you did I mean I did you
got you really got screwed over yeah and
that was of course a that was on a USO
tour yeah yeah it was joking around she
had a bulletproof vest of course yeah if
you look at the picture it it kind of
proves that I wasn't doing that yeah she
had anyway especially in the time of
like Roy Moore and then the Democrats
just turned on you no that's exactly
what happened it was time perfectly
right she anyway I you know uh I should
have had due process yeah I had my my
colleagues at 36 Democratic colleagues
the man that I resigned it's uh
Democrats started this thing of eating
their own were they really I I was the
thing I mean yeah yeah yeah it sucks you
got to be with a poster boy for that but
it's mostly timing
well it was timing by the person
sorry for sure so uh but when you see
this stuff on Twitter with like you know
Bill Murray and stuff and people I mean
are you on Twitter do you check it at
all I don't check that yeah uh but uh
yeah I know I mean I know Billy I and
you know I feel
feel awful but and I don't know what it
was and I don't know if he was joking
around I think he
from what I understood he went her over
to do like the kiss on you know when we
on uh VE Day right right oh yeah and um
so I don't know all right yeah so you
were there like Eddie Murphy first comes
on I was not oh you weren't you've gone
there again I did the first five years
left when Lauren left left or came back
when Lauren came out how many years five
years oh wow so I was a born-again
writer and so it was Lauren again yeah I
was gone I left May 80 and came back
eight of uh fall of 85 I guess what do
you think Albert Brooks oh smartest guy
on the planet brilliant comedic mind
yeah he uh him and Downey I'd say Downey
yeah down he's number one yeah uh well I
mean I don't know Albert and I wrote so
much with Downey down here I wrote a lot
of the political stuff on the show we
had a this Downey's motto that we would
uh reward people for knowing stuff but
not punish them for not knowing stuff oh
that's good that's a very uh lofty
and but we did that well there's nothing
worse than when someone is trying to
show how smart they are right in a
condescending way and you're just you're
just leaving people out I mean the job
is to entertain is to connect right yeah
and that's what we said and and what
what it meant was the people were kind
of political junkies would get something
out of it going like oh
and but people who weren't got
everything we were doing right you know
and that that thing that someone got was
beside the point in the sketch I I was
very proud of that material and we did
Downey's as as
brilliant as they come to Albert
did films the first year wow and uh
remember the impossible truth and I
remember one joke which was uh Israel
and Georgia trade places
and uh the Israeli Prime Minister goes
oh no no the Georgia uh Governor goes
I'll look forward to heat without
humidity
that was that was what he said at the
press conference right if you can you
can dig that up it'll be worth doing
oh my God okay
[Music]
you know something that was pretty funny
you should think about being a comedian
[Laughter]
good comedy Talent
[Laughter]
so I say why not find out
yes
that will tell us in just five short
minutes whether or not you have a future
in comedy
about that first out of me if you will
let's have a brief look at the school
I think you'll like what you see
first day we'll visit comedy tech class
here the students practice all the
Kaiser tanks
and today they're working on the spit
tent now paid so famous by Danny Thomas
on make room for dance
would come in with some surprising news
then it would spit the coffee all over
sit in the heart
that was pretty good but I'd like to try
it just one more time
now start to drink
it's a great premise
[Laughter]
Ah that's great
wow great take so it's a great angle so
do you miss that do you miss being in a
writer's room and just being silly as
hell that's there's nothing more fun
yeah I mean there's nothing more fun
than
just you know especially when it's your
[ __ ] job yeah and you got a show to
put on and
you or someone else comes up with
something you go like oh good the show's
gonna be funny who's the coolest host
that came on oh
I know the worst who's the worst you
know Steven Seagal right terrible
but it's on brand
it is on brand I don't know if he knows
that
but but it's certainly on brand right
right yeah he was uh he lapped everybody
else I mean he was so bad there were
some there are very few bad hosts a few
more laps we'll get back to that uh that
goal weight he was at a while ago oh
yeah
he's gotten big he's large now
that was a fat joke
okay see that with the hit in the
writer's room yeah
what about uh who's the best
well Steve Martin is when he first come
on came on it was like I remember it was
like do we want this guy to host and
then we saw like one of his his Carson
heads and went yeah and then he was yeah
a monster just Monster but they're
amazing number of really great hosts in
different ways but yeah a lot a lot of
greenhouse yeah Steve Martin I mean he
would kill he did the the wild and crazy
guy
yeah he did yeah that was uh too wild it
was uh
yes him and Danny as to like check
Brothers right picking up women and uh
uh yeah I mean I wrote some stuff for
that like uh theodorica Bjork a medieval
Barber and
um see the show was so wacky and silly
then now I feel like it's gotten kind of
uh I don't want to say heavy-handed but
it's a little more it's almost more
serious in tackling bigger issues but
back then like the comedy spit take and
the the the medieval Barber you had the
the caveman lawyer the caveman lawyer
that's Jack Handy oh really Frozen
caveman lawyer one of my Phil Hartford
yeah unbelievable were you close with
Phil Hartman uh I wasn't real close to
Phil I was a friend of Phil's but I mean
I wasn't
um but yeah but what a [ __ ] weird
[ __ ] thing that was what a [ __ ] of a
wife yeah
sorry well I mean I think we should be
allowed she killed him come on suicide I
mean yeah I know it's bad it's tragic
and they had kids and it was no he was a
shame on you sorry sorry
all right Madam my God you're gonna cut
that out right
it's certainly a bad thing to do yes but
uh kill a person oh this is like mental
health uh probably a severe mental
health issue
we could say that about School shooters
too we do yeah and they're [ __ ] too how
about that hard to argue all right thank
you we got him back I landed we landed
on our feet yes
no I remember seeing that in the news
the kid and like I think that was like
the first
Celebrity Death that [ __ ] me up when I
was like oh really why I was such a big
fan of it it was I was actually out in
L.A
um interviewing some writers or
something or for a sitcom I was doing
with
and that was just the [ __ ] weirdest
day yeah crazy yeah okay all right we're
back
we're doing comedy so we're talking
about comedy
so uh I mean it's such a weird pivot do
you always knew you know you're going to
be in politics and I know you're a
political News Junkie you did you did
the radio show as well that was the
bridge yeah the bridge was uh the real
Bridge was uh Paul wellson's uh death
and uh Paul was Senator from Minnesota
uh for all you comedy fans yeah right uh
and he in 2002 he was running for
re-election and he was in a deadlock uh
you know the polls were deadlocked and
he had to vote on the Iraq War he's
going to vote against the war as a
friend of his he told me he told other
people I'm this is going to end my
career
to vote against the war because people
Minnesota were for the war yeah large
majority and he voted against it next
poll had him up by seven because people
in Minnesota actually respect the
politician who votes what they believe
in they don't agree with you he died in
a plane crash
uh about a week later about less than
two weeks before the uh the election
Norm Coleman won the Republican he got
seated three months uh after he receded
he
um did an interview with roll call
Capital Hill newspaper and said to be
blunt I'm a 99 improvement over Paul
wellstone and I read that and I went who
the [ __ ] going to run against this guy
wow and uh that's when I decided to
explore it I didn't know if I was going
to be the guy but then I went around you
know campaigning the 06 cycle for a lot
of Democrats running and
I felt like I could do this and I
clobbered in by 312 votes oh nice was
your family supportive of this yeah
and they my wife won it for me yeah
basically she did this ad it was a such
a moving ad about
she's in recovery and she did it about
and I'd written a couple movies about
the Stuart Smalley here
codependency yeah and uh hey
Garcia yeah and um
so I
so anyway she did this I had the blue
people away and the next debate when she
came into this big gymnasium a high
school gymnasium and she walked in she
got a standio whoa tired Jim were you
jealous as the performer no no I was so
[ __ ] happy because I'm gonna go I'm
gonna win
he's winning this for me yeah I thought
of Stuart schmalley and I always think
of the sketch you did with Michael
Jordan as like oh it's like an iconic
SNL unreal if you could pull that up it
was uh how would you describe Stuart
small he's kind of like a self-help uh
he he had a self-help show Daily
Affirmations yes he was a uh you know a
not a licensed therapist but a member of
several 12-step programs
again this is ahead of its time too
this is ahead of its time too before
everybody got super into it Michael J
I'll protect your anonymity
okay
Michael is a basketball player or a
professional basketball team well that's
very good Michael you should be very
proud of that well
good for you good for you
uh Michael yeah that's great I know
there must be a lot of pressure for you
to play very well and I can imagine that
a night before a game you must lie awake
thinking
I'm not good enough
everybody's better than me I'm not gonna
score any point I have no business
playing this game
well not really Michael
no no
he can't ask them just do it he didn't
get an answer well I do sometimes get a
little nervous oh yeah then you just
skipped over the punchline
[Music]
it's okay it's okay this is the new
generation
believe me I know what it's like Jesus
laying there awake
there no we I just want to curl up and
lay in bed all day and eat pigments
yeah yeah why don't you go toward the
end there well Michael
okay there we go there we go that's what
you're going for I know hello Michael
I don't have to be a great basketball
player I don't have to be a great
basketballer I don't have to dribble the
ball fast or throw this is going into
basket
I don't have to dribble the ball fast or
throw the back ball in the basket
because
all I have to do is be the best Michael
I can be
all I have to do is be the best Michael
I can be because I'm good enough
I'm smart enough and doggone it people
like me
that's killer
amounts of homes everybody's laughs
and dog on it people like me
there we go there you go that's fine
well it was literally the best athlete
of I mean the best basketball player
ever totally yeah I mean this was
amazing I mean to have Michael Jordan
there and this is the year the first
time they allowed Pros to play in the
Olympics oh and
this is 92. yeah and he's like the most
confident guy in the world and I
remember going out of the dressing room
just going like okay so you're yeah how
you feel are you you're gonna win you're
gonna get the gold medal fixing one
yeah I mean he just I mean they and of
course they just wiped of course and it
was magic and it was like crazy
wow and uh but no he he and then this is
you know it's a live show right so when
it Peaks on air
you're really happy and I peeked down
here yeah and a lot of people think oh
athletes are not funny they're not funny
but who can take Direction and be in the
pocket more than an athlete my wife
Franny had the first idea for an athlete
as host it was Fran tarkinson
Vikings fan oh quarterback for the bikes
got it who had lost by this point
several he just lost the Super Bowl
again and for the bikes and uh for any
had this idea and we did it and I
remember Belushi who played linebacker
in high school made me go over his house
and read the entire Dick Butkus
autobiography to me Jesus and uh so I
could write a an authentic locker room
sketch or something and
um uh so and then you know we've had
amazing we had Bill Russell we had uh
Peyton Manning when I wasn't there that
was the best he's very fun athlete host
yeah he gets he gets had to be funny I
mean uh yeah he really guesses and
Michael I mean part of the funny I mean
the fact that he is trying not to break
is so funny yes literally it was how
satisfying is that you're like Michael
Jordan's trying to hold it together I
think he broke in in dress yeah and I
just said don't break hmm hey folks we
might be drunk It's brought to you by
bespokes posts box of awesome is easy to
remember because every time you open one
you just think awesome bespoke post
partners with small business and
emerging Brands to bring you the most
unique Goods every month from cozy
Essentials to cocktail kits box of
awesome has everything you need for
winter
we love these guys they're sending over
a cast box we got it right here whoa
personal sized aging barrel for your
favorite cocktail holy look at that beer
Jew wow we can make our own stuff if
only we had our own whiskey
just take the quiz at boxofawesome.com
and they'll pick the right box of
awesome for you you only pay a fraction
of what these boxes are worth Plus 90 of
everything in your box is from a small
up and coming brand like Bodega cat and
bubble wrap
can't go wrong it's free to sign up and
you can skip a month or cancel any time
get 20 off your first monthly box when
you sign up at box of awesome.com and
enter the code drunk at checkout
never fails that's box of awesome.com
code drunk for 20 off your first box box
of awesome.com promo code drunk
hey folks this episode is sponsored by
betterhelp look Adidas dropped Kanye so
to Balenciaga better help should pick up
Kanye he needs it if life came with a
user manual things would be easy for
everyone but it isn't so when it's not
working for you it's normal to feel
stuck navigating a career change a new
relationship or beginning a parent
becoming a parent can make you feel
uncertain therapists are trained to help
you learn productive coping skills which
makes therapy the closest thing you'll
get to a user manual for you we all go
to therapy we all go to the same guy
love him love him it's a game changer
you got me in I'm hooked he knows me too
well I know we were talking the other
day about a toxic woman and he goes uh
you're not done with her I was like yes
I am because I know how you are you love
it I'm like I was like [ __ ] you Alan man
he's good oh yeah he is good better help
us online there with Oliver's video
phone and chat therapy sessions you can
chew used to to not see anyone on camera
if that makes you feel better tell them
how to do it fatty as the world's
largest therapy service better help has
Match 3 million people with
professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
if things aren't clicking you can easily
switch back to a new therapist anytime
it couldn't be simpler no waiting rooms
no traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist learn more and save 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
drunk that's better
help.com slash drunk
diet smoke is the solution to avoid
those oh [ __ ] I'm way too high moments
diet smoke makes Delta 8 THC Delta 9 THC
and CBD products that are perfectly
balanced their gummies drinks Vapes all
delicious they're guaranteed to give you
a beautiful Buzz you've been looking for
without melting you into the couch their
extract is THC and CBD from American
grown hemp and shipped directly to your
door no prescription no sketchy weed
dealer no need to leave the house even
tell them how diet smoke just released a
bunch of new products and flavors no
matter what type of mood you're in they
got you covered if you're ready for that
perfect high head over to dietsmoke.com
use code drunk for 20 off your entire
purchase must be 21 or older to order
see he's in the pocket he's in the
pocket what uh was he fun to deal with
as a host yeah yeah but it was also like
again the most secure confident person
in the world you're dealing with unlike
some of the shitty hosts and there are
very few who else is shitty oh uh oh
shoot the British actor Hugh Grant no no
I don't I'm sure he's great I'm sure
everyone he's a good actor there are
very few oh gosh who is the guy is it
damaged damn it Jeremy Irons
Jeremy Irons uh
um he's a real Coach
has a very good story I think I can say
Odin Cooks a terrible host no no holding
her is the best guy but he was a writer
on the show and uh he didn't get a shine
on SNL Bob Odenkirk oh yeah no he was a
writer
yeah but he wrote the van down by the
river Farley he wrote that yeah yeah
yeah
done it at Second City wow I didn't know
that yeah
but he got he got a shine after on like
the Ben Stiller show and Mr show he they
never did you guys know that you're like
this dude can no act no you didn't know
he could perform like that I knew he uh
not really I had
um
he worked in a group with Smigel in
Chicago at one point I think he
substituted and I Tom Davis and I did a
movie in Chicago
and one of their they had a group
you know an improv group that was
uh that one of our cast members was in
so Odenkirk filled in for that guy and I
went to see them and I I was one I
figured out that's my goal as the guy
who wrote this most of the stuff in that
yeah and uh could Bob just substituted
in he hadn't written the stuff and
that's how Smiggle got there so ah okay
he's uh he's an asset might as well my
Discerning Eye yes good eye because he's
an asset I mean he he killed it
unbelievable I just watched the uh the
Dana Carvey documentary on H on Hulu
it's hilarious
so they really went they fell on the
swords they would not not do the Bill
Clinton breastfeeding oh the nipples
yeah they opened with that and it just
killed them and they also they were
following
um Home Improvement
it's the most like broad show yeah
abroad and and at times very sappy yeah
right and leading up to and that had
Colbert had uh Carell Louisiana yeah
Louie I mean it's Michael how does that
show not I mean Dana Carvey was he one
of the funniest dudes to be around he is
so funny yeah he is he's a star
endlessly hilarious and uh and a lovely
guy and just
my God I mean and His Voice work is
amazing his impressions are amazing the
thing about Dana is I wrote a lot of the
political stuff
um he he did George H.W bush and we
could we just use that as a crutch we
could open the show with a great opening
with a and Downing and I used to write
them and sometimes Dana would kick in
Dana knows his politics and he but so we
would write something where there was a
logic to it there was it was one okay
I'll give you one it's it was drugs were
in the news so HW is going like
um from the White House from his desk
are you going this vial of crack
was found across the street at Lafayette
Park
across the street from the White House
this hypodermic needle was found on the
White House lawn
this bag of cocaine was found three feet
from this desk here okay so Dana could
get laughs doing
just that right just get endless laughs
doing that [ __ ] so we would have to
before you run it we would have to say
to him
in dress after he would get so many
laughs and dress that you would lose the
through line oh wow and we'd go up to
him Danny and I would go up to him and
go like okay that's what's happening and
he did it almost every week yeah so he
would he knew exactly how much to dial
it back
and he's just
an amazing performance he could have
been a great dramatic actor if he ever
wanted to do that I don't think he wants
to do that yeah I think he would want
but I remember my brother showing me the
movie Opportunity Knocks when we were a
kid oh yeah thinking it was like the
funniest thing I'd ever seen we had it
on VHS he must have watched it like 15
times yeah and he's just doing the bush
character in one of the scenes he was
just pushing that accent whatever
because he just knew it was going to hit
totally it [ __ ] hit play the clip
oh
thank you
spending relief sending it down there
not too much not too quickly
wouldn't be prudent
and the drug problem
s
right here
in the White House
[Laughter]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
LR kids that it's bad
[Laughter]
interdiction maybe maybe there's no I
think that was the crack I saw I see
have you ever seen him bomb like he has
no inhibition he's just going like you
know when you're killing on stage you're
still all right here's my next joke here
comes the line you know you're still in
the moment working he doesn't he feels
like he's having fun and still killing
well that's part of his charm he was
having fun and also you know you like
that character yes HW loses
uh you know to Clinton in 92 invites
Dana to the White House
not trumpian yeah good point good point
he wanted to be made fun of he wanted to
be he's a man he understood it and and
of course the way they made fun of trump
was not affectionate at all but uh I
went down when Dana hosted uh I went
down to Houston and taped something with
HW and he was
um it's funny because he was an
ex-president so I was instructed only
one take he'll only do one take and the
first take wasn't
was 80 or something sure and I'm scared
oh okay I'm gonna have to and he did 12
takes oh wow but if you're the assistant
the staffer for a former president
United States you say to a comedy
[ __ ] no one take of course and then
he just was
he wanted to nail it and he did and he
did a cold opening with uh or the
monologue you made a good point about
the Trump thing though because the the
impression is really not done with love
at all you know when Alec Baldwin was
doing it that was it wasn't necessarily
an accurate impression compared to what
some of these it wasn't very good
actually the uh what's his name he's so
good the guy
no no no no uh three names uh Johnson
Johnson oh is he on the cast yeah he's
not oh okay come on I should know sorry
uh he does an amazing Trump James Austin
Johnson yeah James
he discovered is just what what he does
which is just free associate that's
right Trump's
strengths you know I always thought he
could riff that Trump part of the reason
he won in 16 was that he's a stand-up in
another way sure he I've never seen the
man laugh
it's true but he could go out there in
front of a crowd and riff
for an hour 15. oh Jeb Bush melted and
the dude he like stuck to a script you
know right well yeah every Everybody he
there was he sucked up every bit of
oxygen yeah and so CNN would just cut
to him doing and he was my my theory is
that
um you know build a wall and Mexico is
going to pay for it was just a that just
became His Hot Pockets I think he just
he just kind of went he said it once and
he just went nuts and he just kept
saying it was his Hot Pockets that
wasn't like some Theory I think they
were going to say do the Mexican board
do the board the border and he comes up
with that and then boom we have to close
down the government later yeah let me
see this guy I've never seen this uh you
know and more specifically
and you know what now they want to go
beyond Burger can you believe that I
want to stay right at Burger oh that's
good
Joe Biden has gone beyond burger and it
is not gonna score and you know what
neither has reboot of fresh prince it's
very different and I'm laughing and I'm
laughing and I'm laughing but I don't
know why
yeah he's good but Shane I do think
Shane Gillis does the best one I've ever
seen and I do but a lot of it's the
writing you know well some people do
some amazing ones but
um that's he just he discovered this
random stuff that he does right better
than anyone I've seen well I think
what's good about Shane's is that he
he's not really he's not really picking
aside he's just being funny you know I
think that was much of a side there no
no absolutely I I haven't seen enough of
that guy but this this is Trump speed
date and I think this is gold
that's what we're going to call her Tana
It the clown she looks like him
bothering children
oh the little things
I saw you walk in I said who's this
yeah what's great about Shane is that he
he that Trump wins in this sketch in his
mind but he doesn't win right that's
kind of the beauty of it like he's like
in his mind he's winning right it's like
the ego trumps all and that's kind of
why I love this and I mean but the
writing is so very funny uh observation
but both him and you right well you know
it's uh it's so I mean of course you're
right you can get away with more on
YouTube sure sure on SNL but like yeah
but when you make fun of someone and
it's like when you roast someone and you
go like the Chevy Chase roast is a good
example it's a weird roast because you
can tell they all [ __ ] hated him it's
awkward and and then it wasn't hating
him it was maybe there was some there
but mainly it was mainly it was easy to
make fun of at that point in his career
but his friends hated him and they
didn't show up is is my point and then
the guys are the guys who didn't show up
but if you love the guy you're showing
up to the roast right I think it was
Marty and Steve who had done Three
Amigos with him just didn't show up but
it might have been
my point is it's the first roast where
you're like oh these are just all casted
Roasters these aren't his friends it was
like Marc Maron young Greg Gerald Norton
it was just all Roasters who were like
they don't even know the guy not Barry
Hill killed it he killed a great joke
which is making fun of Chevy Chase isn't
as easy as shooting fish in the barrel
it's as easy as being in a room with a
barrel
[Laughter]
no dude I I wonder if there's footage of
it anywhere it's one of the best Rose
sets I've ever seen I it was did you see
the uncensored roast is that what you've
I mean because it must be up there
there's one aired and there's one which
is uh I I do have a copy of the whole
roast that's it that's but you're not
pull that up now
nope pull that up the uh usually have a
bartender but there is something about
you know when you when you yeah the uh
Colbert the Chevy Chase Rose but there's
something about when you when you don't
like the person and you're making fun of
them it that's the thing about politics
is you have to you ever try to write a
joke when you like when you just have a
breakup and it's too raw it's too real
it's too real and you're like oh that's
kind of a me it's either too mean about
her or too self-deprecating about
yourself you haven't found that balance
and I think it works similarly with an
impression or a roast you need to take
yourself emotionally a little bit out of
it and just be funny yes yeah if you can
feel the tension and the Venom it's not
as funny
really is that a good rule
sorry she's really involved a fair
amount of good-natured ribbing
but uh when I was asked to do this I was
informed ouch actually going to be
honoring Mr Chase
I'm appalled at some of the things that
I have heard said about this man
I don't really mean out here I mean
backstage
[Laughter]
to attack Chevy Chase I don't know Chevy
Chase I have never met Mr Chase I'm
actually I'm uncomfortable calling him
Chevy the only thing I think of when I
look at this man is there but for the oh
god
oh he smirked he won't give him the
laugh
[Applause]
[Laughter]
of Hollywood some sort of walking waking
cautionary tale shapeless Jesus
wow I think you that was that would be
good that would be good
but it was beautifully written and uh if
Chevy were a little smarter at that
moment or less
under attack
secure he would have laughed very hard
there you go here I mean it's funny that
Trump had a roast on Comedy Central oh
yeah another guy you don't think of is I
wonder what role Jeff Ross
all right well you know Jeff Ross has a
big role The Rose Master and
but I'm not sure I don't think Jeff was
part of that one it might have been
before his time yeah yeah
oh yeah 20 years of Jesus Christ wow so
much has changed he wasn't home alone
for Christ's sake Trump home alone too
tell sorry second one and WrestleMania
probably won't be in Home Alone 12. they
made they've made a bunch more yeah have
you watched Home Alone recently I think
I was a kid it's not a good movie oh it
is
solid the second one is terrible well
I'm talking about the first one the
first one is good you can't yeah come on
the first one is really really are you a
big movie guy
not as big as a lot of people who aren't
show buses I mean I yeah but that I
think that was a really that's a solid
move can you give us a movie rack
we like wrecks on this podcast election
oh it's one of my all-time favorites
Thomas Paine yeah
home alone too yeah
um no election phenomenal I think it's
pain yeah no that's right yeah yeah I
think there's a team there's a like
one's a director one's a writer or
something like this look it up one of
one of my favorite comedies of all time
it's brilliant brilliant it's a good
dark you know my son at the time it was
nine years old and he saw and my son's
reaction was I remember that was 2000
because I remember this because I took
my son and his friend out to LA for the
Democratic Convention that Gore was
nominated so that's how I remember and
um we went to some party where the I
think the guys who wrote it maybe was
saying I don't know were there and he
just went up to them and said
the you the cars that you picked out
were perfect and he's a production
design he might my son is nine years old
because he's a car nut oh really just
love the car that um
and he just my my son loved everything
about the production design nine years
old and he's not interested he doesn't
care about production design normally at
all he cares about cars so no he's a
great filmmaker it stands out extra in a
comedy because usually you don't always
yeah like the comedy director someone's
directors try to do too much in a comedy
you're like well that's not good but it
worked oh my God perfectly but anyway so
you asked for recommendations keep it at
one that's a great one good Strange Love
of course of course great one classic
classic yeah yeah I got I got so many
questions I don't want to bug you first
of all I know that's why okay here I
know you did blow with Belushi we got to
get into that yes but how was that
he would have too much
you don't say it was funny when
um I hated uh Bob Woodward's book on him
wired because it was all about his drug
use and uh
uh Tom Davis said it was like as if
someone uh named your college yearbook
puked
and all he did was puke no one learned
math or right yeah one-sided you know
and I remember uh Woodward interviewed
me and
he asked me about cocaine and I said the
only time I ever did cocaine was with
Bernstein
because I just didn't like the whole
tone of this guy yeah yeah sure and I
thought the book was a travesty and it
was like Lauren said it was written by a
guy didn't understand anything about
popular culture and bougie's place in it
and he said this Lawrence said it was
like he he had written a sentence that
said the Beatles a popular musical group
in the 60s you know and yeah it was uh I
was very offended by the that book yeah
because he's just a brilliant performer
sure none of that is captured it's just
all I they were from the same town in uh
in Chicago I can't remember the name of
the town but it was almost like him
saying I'm the best guy from this oh
that's I had to feel of it what does it
mean things
there you go third one I got in yeah he
didn't stop you on that one ah he's back
in nobody I wouldn't call him that
either no that's a great one call back
Al come on I didn't like the book was
[ __ ] there we go there we go it's a
good adjective all right
no it was a uh it was a special time at
that cast and you think about I do think
about you know someone says Comics like
we this podcast started because Mark and
I used to get drunk all the time
together you know we were young Road
comics and then slowly used to
we made it we built the show around it
but true When We Were Young Comics you
know you can get hammered every night
and then you start going on the road and
we'd see each other I don't know maybe
two days a week maybe one day a week and
we'd try to make that one night count
we'd say hey let's let's hang then
before we'd know it it's 5 a.m and we
keep saying one more drink one more
drink six seven a.m turned into a
podcast oh look at us Jesus
banged up right there I'm hurting too I
look like I've been black face Mickey
Mantle regretted drinking as much as he
did he did oh is that right well
everybody says that after during that
was a blast it was interesting he didn't
he said you know Pete Rose took care of
himself I mean all these guys that had
these careers 536 home runs with a
drinking problem though that's a
functioning alcoholic you know you don't
have to don't do this but because it's
not that great but uh some of the
interviews he did on Letterman toward
the end of his career about
just getting so [ __ ] wasted and being
at somebody's farm and and wasted and
then
came into the ballpark and just falling
asleep in the Dugout and being you know
like you're gonna get up and then
hitting a home run over the center field
in Yankee Stadium wow see to me that's a
tale of an incredible functioning
alcoholic yes that's a win yes and no I
mean but he his career was shorter than
it needed to be no I mean sure for sure
we don't need to talk about real
drinking on this but this is becoming a
buzz kill right now I mean by the way
don't let the show
suggest to you that it's okay if you
have a drinking problem you put the Al
and Alan on
you cut the mark and I in 20 years in
this podcast I think I made every
mistake a man can make that's my one
regret was drinking too much I I think
probably you should save that little
clip with me your audience the most
important thing ever said you got it
don't drink here
I really hope Al gets wasted here now
he's like don't get a little tipsy very
easily really oh okay let's do shots
we'll take a cat shots and I don't like
Hardware I don't I just you're a beer
guy
I drink beers occasionally I'll bring a
glass of wine occasionally but I don't I
don't drink I don't
I don't care you sound healthy you look
yeah you look good full head of hair
yes well dude and not drinking I I I I
I'm pretty I had back surgery five weeks
so did he no I had like an ablation I
had a my neck I had a real yeah yeah but
I'm good it was a great
yeah I mean carrying SNL for 10 years
never mind all right sorry this episode
this episode's had more
than we've ever had
you were in Trading Places I Remember
was that right yeah I do remember that
yeah well that was very Chris Farley
that was pretty cool I mean that was a
pretty great scene though you're in the
end of the movie The Gorilla Brothers
where we come in there uh with Eddie and
Danny and I was Eddie and Danny and that
yeah yeah uh gee which was that at that
character actor was so great and uh Den
home Elliott
no no Dan home oh yeah was a different
he was the butler yeah he was a butler
damn he was funny yeah what what about
uh were they cool to work with awkward
and Eddie Murphy oh yeah but we barely I
mean we just had a couple scenes and one
was uh with them and so mainly we were
just in a trailer waiting for our scene
of course you know and I was Stone bag
Chandler one and Tom was Stone baggage
handler two we smoke a joint in it and
later they figured out that Eddie should
smoke a joint so they did they took that
scene out so we were just really just
stupid
baggage handler one stupid baggage
handler too right we were playing very
stoned and
I love it yeah yeah well you know I mean
I get people come may all you know say
to me usually around Christmas or
something and see how much they love
it's such a Christmas movie it is isn't
it yeah it's such a like what are your
all-time Christmas movies for me that's
in there I I love bad santa that movie
oh I do too it's like a warm blanket
that movie it's so have you seen that
one no I gotta see it great movie
uh yeah I mean there's all the classics
on vacation vacation so good
weapons at Christmas no no Die Hard Die
Hard really what I don't remember that
the director or that writer's Hallmark
is setting movies Shane black no you
know what's a really good Thomas movie
It's a Wonderful Life that's a great
movie
no but that is a great movie it is so
it's great movie fact about that movie
apparently Jimmy Stewart was Furious
that it bombed he blamed the lead
actress
yeah oh that it bombed yeah because it
didn't do well in theaters that's right
yeah she was a [ __ ]
he lived long enough to see it was yeah
yeah you got that right yeah no that's a
it's a great movie it plays with the IFC
every year and I went with my girlfriend
wife and we took Edibles and uh we were
laughing so much in the first eight
minutes of the movie that a guy turned
around and goes shut the [ __ ] up with my
dad now we're like we ran out
good times I went there with my ex and
we uh we did heroin and it's great great
he were quiet the whole time no not yet
my wife and I did no all right now I
never got to my second question because
I wanted we got another Bob or the
cocaine with the Belushi
political guy obviously you've seen it
all you've been through it have you ever
seen it as bad as it is today with
politics and the tribal and the fighting
and the whole thing it has gotten worse
and worse and I trump it was the kind of
a a a kind of a Tipping Point sure
because this is a you know a very uh
sick
guy right and
um you know with all the disinformation
out there there a lot of people bought
into them some probably watching this
podcast that guy yeah
[Laughter]
um
and it's and and you know we're taping
this uh not long after just a few days
after the midterms and my wife said
the night after she said it was the
American people saying stop it and it
really was saying stop it to this denial
of that the election about the election
and
um you know our democracy but some of
those people won some of those people
that that are someone but none like who
are in a position to like the
secretaries of State Canada's for uh and
they were upsets for sure but uh but
like the Secretary of State in Most
states runs the elections in the state
and there were a number of
you know a rabid deniers who ran for
Secretary of State like Michigan and in
um well the governor the guy ran for
governor in Pennsylvania you know bus
people to because on January 6. he lost
handily and the uh the governor appoints
the Secretary of State in Pennsylvania
so that was at stake and uh and you know
so deniers got what was funniest to me
was that these deniers who their whole
political identity was that the uh 20
election was stolen a number of them
conceded
which was like I know I've just staked
my entire political identity on saying
that the 20 election was uh stolen and
despite there being no evidence and 61
two cases decided again wow and despite
this and despite this I that's what I
ran on and good for them last night I I
can see and I'm going like I think it
works like that wow yeah but not all
yeah and what do you think about like a
state like Pennsylvania where you know
pretty close race but you know fetterman
wins and uh do you think how much do
that do you think is like Dr Oz being an
out of town like New Jersey guy how much
of it do you think is like there were a
lot he had a lot of baggage in that he
also
um
I don't he didn't come off very well he
came off his little like too slick at
least either of them did yeah
fetterman this was unprecedented that
that debate was unprecedented because
you're watching a guy
who has not recovered yet from a stroke
from a stroke and
took a lot of courage to do it but in a
way he couldn't not do it yeah so you're
watching something completely just the
how you process that uh Oz made this
mistake by saying abortion should
between be between a woman her doctor
and her local politician
remember he said that and that just gave
them an ad right and
um and of course you know
uh they were able to cut together ads
for fetterman too from where he was
going you know uh very coherent and uh
he opened by saying good night which was
fun yeah I mean
uh and in a way that's kind of when when
he won and and
um uh you know gave his victory speech
it was kind of moving yeah for a guy to
sure you know and
um
so no that that's
nothing like that has ever happened
before yeah but can we come back to
normal at all or is are we is this just
how it's going to be now these two camps
who just hate each other and don't
listen and no discussion I think it's
gonna be very interesting to watch the
Republican party now because there's
going to be a lot of recriminations and
I think it'll be a [ __ ] show because so
many of them and again this is sounding
pretty partisan political but you could
divide the office holders
and the apparatics of the Republican
party and do chicken shits who wouldn't
say but won the election because they
didn't want to get on the wrong side of
trump and then the kind of The Crazies
and they're going to be fighting and uh
they barely I don't it hasn't been quite
determined yet but it looks like they're
going to have a very narrow margin in
the house so there's going to be a lot
of
fighting and and what's funny now is as
we speak I'm not sure when you're airing
this but uh Herschel Walker is the
remaining candidate so this might be
coming out after the runoff yeah I'm
sure it will probably
[Laughter]
um but uh and you know no 30 years from
now people may say you know Herschel
Walker was one of the great U.S senators
you know what not everyone who pays for
an abortion sends you a card
that's worth more than a Herschel Walker
football I think that I think you're
right
yeah
you're using that aren't you that's it
really yeah I did do I did play just my
advice I played Georgia over the weekend
I was I was uh and after every abortion
joke I would say it's okay Herschel
Walker wrote that one too you know
how many abortion jokes
ironically you won't get rid of them
uh yeah uh but you know I don't right
now because the majority of the Senate
isn't up I just I have a prediction that
Warnock will win that one because there
are a lot of Republicans very close in
the polls of what it was close in the
election but I think there are a lot of
Republicans who
voted for him and now that the majority
and the Senate isn't at stake are they
going like
do I really want to you know
uh you know it used to be that putting a
gun in your wife's head was disqualifier
yeah you know
um
and I just do it to get an erection
thank you very much
but you know uh no you're right and he
it's interesting there's something about
running the celebrities like we talk
about name recognition and it's like you
know the you know Dr Oz Herschel Walker
yeah you know Trump trump like
celebrities Carrie Lake but yeah sure
but but she lost I mean there's
something about uh very attractive yeah
you're into that oh yeah I know she put
out when when it was announced that she
had lost she put out uh you know
arizonans no BS and I just yeah that's
why you lost oh
well yeah I mean look
there's something to be said about that
you know you look at the gore Bush
election like I look at that as a time
where Gore was like it's yours he
basically gave it he didn't want the
Supreme Court what do you do what it was
the Supreme Court I know but it was he
he very gracefully handed it over right
I mean that wouldn't happen now I would
never be
respect the legitimacy of the Court
something that's harder to do now after
they didn't take up Merrick Garland and
after they sat Tony Barrett nine days
before an election but
um but at that time there was a lot of
respect for the legitimacy of the court
and that's what Gore was recognizing
that that's it that's that's the Supreme
Court do you think this would be
happening at this level if if Democrats
weren't constantly you know after the
Trump election you know someone like
Rachel Maddow the steel dossier like the
meddling do you think that would it
would be going to this level if it
weren't for that
oh yeah I mean because
uh
uh yeah I I think that the steel dossier
is something obviously used and I guess
in some respect right rightfully is as a
little bit of a weapon but no that's
with this is about having this guy who
uh you know just a guy a pathological
liar
a guy who says you know I can shoot
someone on Fifth Avenue
and not lose a vote and you go okay but
you'd be prosecuted
right
I know that's true I mean but
uh do you think you have enough pull to
get Hunter Biden on this podcast
uh there'll be a lot of funny stuff in
the investigation we got a footballer
yeah we get a full ball it'll be like
that bush sketch I got a bag of crack
oh yeah they're gonna do it if they have
the majority they're going to do it you
know what how do we get back I mean you
are a politician that looked to unite
and not divide people how do you how do
we get back yes mentality how do we get
back to like you know Mark and I we're
Road Comics we take pride in letting
everyone in on the joke that is kind of
what we try to do as entertainers and I
think really good politicians have a
similar yeah ability right I mean how do
we get back to it or are we doomed with
Twitter and all this you know
tribalistic division yeah
what makes me pessimistic is just the
divide in terms of information and the
disinformation that we people buy into
and if you're in your that Universe of
information
uh that division is gonna
uh that just division is going to be
there and but I think the internet is
coming in with a little bit of Middle
Ground you know because it obviously
policy here but section 230 is something
I would change and that's the thing that
says that these like Facebook is a
platform and can't be responsible for
stuff it puts out but that Facebook has
their algorithm knows you better than
yeah know yourself they say it knows
you're gay before you do yeah and and
basically so I found out
it basically feeds you gives you back
what will keep you on on on Facebook Oh
They'll recommend me like a sweater
though I should get that and I'm like
wait a second yeah they got you it's
crazy right they're probably right yeah
you should probably get that I'm gonna
get it let me get back on real quick
they know you better than you know you
but what I'm saying is they also like to
keep people on and get them agitated so
they stay on right they know everybody
so well they go this guy
we feed him some this disinformation
he'll get really excited about it and
stay on longer and we sell advertising
that's bad news so they know what
they're doing they know exactly what
they're giving you yeah the way you're
talking I'm like you you are a voice
that could really do good and part of me
thinks like man it's it's a bummer that
you're that you're not are there is
there any hope you would get back in I'm
keeping my options open but um it is
pretty toxic you sound like my ex right
now
this is what he says huh
you should I mean you should think of
your ex but I'm sure that's accurate
yeah
but you don't want to go dip your toe
back in uh I don't know I don't know it
depends I mean I'm still a Minnesotan at
heart and I go back and forth but I have
grandchildren here so I'm here a lot and
um La so I'm a little
um
you know I'm a little bit being Grandpa
and I'm doing a podcast and uh and
um and I'm on the road I'm on the Jesus
Christ that's why my oh I'm here I'm
doing the alpha not just to hang out
with us and get drunk with us yeah yeah
but that too but uh yeah I'm on tour I'm
on oh here we go what do we got here the
only former U.S senator currently on
tour tour here here we are there's I'm
going to Portland and then Sacramento
I'm doing a little West Coast I just did
that Revolution Hall it's great isn't
that great great that's great I love
Portland audiences don't make it schools
I'm doing San Luis Obispo and then Los
Angeles
California I was working one of the
things you guys sent like subjects to
think about is like bits you're working
on yeah oh please no I was just thinking
it in Portland of course they have this
huge homeless problem you got that right
and so
last time I was there or maybe it was
two times ago or something that a lot of
the homeless people were wearing
um uh Nike is Nike there or is it yeah
yeah
they're wearing Nike stuff and what
happened was the Nike
had decided uh to give the homeless
people Nike clothes
and uh now they were stopping to do it
because a lot of people
think that they were all just former
Nike employees oh wow that the homeless
I blew all this money on Jordans
video yeah I mean it but yeah it was
okay bad idea to give now do they give
the kids of the sweatshops free Nikes
they don't not they probably they
probably don't Adidas so those kids stop
working ironically they'd get free [ __ ]
because they'd be homeless you see a
homeless guy in Asics you're like all
right this guy I'll give him some money
but nice yeah he's a real hobo yeah huh
[Music]
yeah
so anyway I've been yeah I've been on uh
doing this tour and you asked me about
uh when I got here am I still uh working
out at the cellar yeah and I haven't
been lately I've been uh working out a
little on a club that's two blocks of my
house on the west side west side comedy
club uh we're neighbors man we were
neighbors yeah and but I love the seller
and that's what happened when I when I
left Santa I started giving speeches and
I realized like this is like 80 funny
and also I love stand up and I had never
really done it by myself I don't know
with Tom all these years right and uh so
I started working out at the seller and
um kill right away yay
and uh very comfortable doing it and
um
uh just love doing it as you guys that
is just it's a gas I mean it's amazing
it's tough to oh sorry go ahead you're
tough to follow because you have Smart
intellectual thoughtful stuff and then
I'm like hey pedophiles huh and so
they're like well we that guy would
follow me all right that's what you say
to pedophiles
[Laughter]
what I can do with the seller what's
funny at the seller is everyone
three quarters of the time I can open
with
you know well uh you know Cecile just uh
kill but no wonder
she stole all my material and it always
gets a big lamp because it's so [ __ ]
dirty here
yeah or you know uh someone uses the
n-word constantly yes sorry about that
all right usually it's a black comedian
usually always I used to write for
Michael Richards
all right very good good to have you
back
[Laughter]
so and you bring Dina Hashem on the road
sometimes
right I brought her for a couple things
very funny right yeah Dina is great and
um I brought her out uh I did like an uh
Eastern Long Island where was River uh
Riverhead yep and uh then also
Minneapolis and yeah she's
hilarious yeah great joke writer yeah
when is this episode coming out man
so Dina Hashem is actually recording an
album or special in Chicago this weekend
check that out highly recommend going it
might be sold out by now but two shows
at the Lincoln Lodge Dina Hashem
hilarious comic
I'm producing it hello James Webb is
directing it he directed my Netflix
special we'll just do all her jokes now
let's burn them all dude yeah
she's a great joke
yeah any pet peeves anything that bother
you lately oh yeah yeah yeah
um okay two things uh one people uh
people who walk down the street on their
phone and I can't believe you probably
haven't heard this one before this is
people walk on the phone don't look
where they're going sure sure and I
wanna I'm thinking of working on a piece
where it's two gen Z people
uh both on their phones walking down the
street and it's just it's very physical
piece it's just boom and they they bump
into each other and their phone goes
into the uh into the gutter and goes
down the thing and it's just the Gen Z
person like oh
because that's I just feel like when
people walking down the street and
they're looking I just I want to go I
know I know and I don't because I
wouldn't all right we've all done it
yeah I've done it on the phone thing one
time I did it and I and I was looking at
my phone and someone else was looking at
the phone and we collided and we were
both mad at the other person
right that's my bed yeah oh no there you
go that's not a great bit but now you
see I don't want to follow them and then
so that's that but the other one is and
I I bet you this is also your pet peeve
and you didn't realize it is it's these
[ __ ] on
um these electric bikes oh yeah who are
going the wrong way in the bike lane
yeah and
and going 40 miles an hour yep and they
decide as I get a green
and the bike lane is this way which I'm
looking for because I don't
wanna you know because I'm on to this
some guy's coming from this way yep and
he knows he's gonna make it he knows
he's not going to hit me but it's like
that close sure but he knows it and I go
like ah yeah like that and he's just
going like I knew I had it
they're going way too fast too yeah for
and they're in a bike lane uh not a bike
is for a pedal bike the pandemic really
made that catch on New York oh yeah
that could be for any hotel joke by the
way yeah that's true it's that
um the guys who deliver food and those
are the guys who are on this bike
they're the third responders
[Laughter]
on this podcast once a week
totally he's our favorite him and Hitler
but could you combine those two and make
the go with the phone guy the bike guy
and then the bike guy on his phone
because I've seen that a lot too Jesus
all right I wish I had seen that so that
could be my pippy oh okay I'm just
saying for the bit for the business is
he uh is it who are your favorites to
watch when you're down at the club now
do you watch comment do you watch Comedy
down there or no well I haven't been
there in a while but Dina I just
discovered that is great and
um
I got you know what a bad on me because
I can't remember some names of of great
comics
yeah yeah it's tough It's been a while
I've been it's been a while yeah plus
you know the age
you're a young whippersnapper though if
you're a politician though now I mean
you look what's out there there's some
there's some really uh strong bad ones I
really you know there's some young bands
so you seem younger than you are I mean
what is 71 yeah hey you see wow 71 yeah
67. yeah something like that
good for you I'm a comedian
no you look great I wish you were my dad
oh I Met Your Dad at the wedding he's a
great guy ah the battle does he watch no
no okay he is a Peeping Tom though yes
[Applause]
you got your podcast got my podcast the
Al Franken podcast we very often have uh
there I am look at that hello I'd vote
for that guy yeah there's no Immortal
team that's a very typical it's quite a
that's a good get uh Norm is uh one of
the great political uh scholars in the
country so that's a good idea
a lot of politics go to the next one
it's uh David Axelrod oh yeah
um uh and Cecile Richards I was in his
podcast sometimes hacks on tap that's a
good one oh really too many ads though
uh it doesn't add every three minutes on
that podcast well on every uh podcast
you get like on my YouTube stuff there
are people just complain about there's
nothing I can do they really stretch
them out on that Mike Murphy and those
guys they'll talk about a mattress for
15 minutes just get back to the show
yeah yeah and that's like what the
30-second thing is made for exactly so
we gotta back forward this comes out the
fourth so yeah I'll be in Tacoma Spokane
uh on New Year's Oklahoma the city and
then the theater tour we start up we got
New Orleans Austin Tulsa
Dallas St Louis Vegas go to samuel.com
for more uh yeah added in Vancouver we
added in Portland uh Seattle all the
dates are up there we're adding dates so
please check it out samrail.com shows
I'm coming everywhere except we haven't
had Cali on this or Denver but we'll be
there soon oh yeah I'm at The Wilbur
coming up uh Fillmore is great great one
of the great rooms in America very steep
uh balcony yes it feels like a club
somehow yeah uh Buffalo Cubs Zanies uh
all kinds of stuff Zanies do you ever do
uh ever play
um the mic and stool no no
I thought there was two guys hey you
guys said huh
[Music]
we're back all right we've come full
circle
make sure oh Mark do you have more to
plug here no no yeah yeah no plug them
oh I'm actually in blue I've been in
Hawaii at the blue note and Honolulu hit
that more oh oh sorry I guess I gotta
get more dates Bodega cat whiskey.com
make sure to order our whiskey it's
great people are snatching it up we are
legal in Texas you can get us any over
200 liquor stores carrying Bodega cat in
Texas holy [ __ ] get on it right you guys
are snatching up we appreciate you guys
so thank you yeah keeping a great guess
man thank you thank you it's an honor
oh good I hope so uh go see Al on tour
listen to his podcast and uh you know
Salamanca you got anything
well as always thank you exciting he's
shooting something well uh you know
thank you is always the Gotham Studios
Matt Peters we love you and uh we'll see
you next week here here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and I get down in the same way
[Music]